[Musik]
der Tag der alles veränderte am 7
oktober ist die Welt für Meron Mendel
stehen
geblieben jeder hat weitergemacht ich
dachte Stopp ich kann es nicht Frieden
für Israel dafür kämpft er in seiner
Heimat und in Deutschland als Junge im
kibuzz als israelischer Soldat als
Direktor der Bildungsstätte Anne Frank
ein Brückenbauer der Kulturen der Israel
liebt und es kritisiert erzogen
zufrieden wir haben euch beigebracht
nicht zu hassen und immer Frieden zu
suchen er reist in sein verwundetes
Heimatland will Familie und Freunden
beistehen gemeinsam trauern verarbeiten
hoffen sie hatte eine besondere Freude
die sie an andere weitergab ich vermisse
sie es ist eine Reise in ein Israel dass
ich neu finden muss in eine vertraute
und doch fremde Heimat mit einer
unsicheren
Zukunft wird Israel den Palästinenser
nach der ham
geben es geht nur mit zwei Staaten es
ist auch eine Reise in die eigene
Vergangenheit zu den eigenen
Überzeugungen was bleibt davon nach dem
7 Oktober und wir denken dass die Losung
ist Frieden es reicht nicht Frieden zu
wollen Meron Mendel will wissen wie kann
es weitergehen mit seinem
Israel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein Koffer voller Schmerz in seiner
Heimat Israel fliegen eigentlich ein
vertrautes Gefühl für Meron Mendel doch
dieses Mal ist alles anders nicht alle
seiner Liebsten haben den Terroranschlag
vom 7 Oktober
überlebt ich bin seit mehr als 20 Jahre
hier in Deutschland aber in dem
Moment diese Jahren habt nicht mehr
gezählt also auf einmal war mir klar
also ich gehöre dahin dass das ist so
der Ort wo ich aufgewachsen bin da da
sind meine kinderheitsfreunde das sind
meine Familie ich muss da sein 2003 kam
Meron Mendel nach Frankfurt heute leitet
er die Bildungsstätte Anne Frank und ist
Professor für Soziale Arbeit verheiratet
ist der 47-Jährige mit der Politologin
sabanur schim sie ist muslimer er ist
Jude gemeinsam setzen sie sich für die
Vielfalt in der Gesellschaft ein ein
herzensthema Frieden in der OST auch
jetzt wie geht es weiter mit Israel für
Meron Mendel eine sehr persönliche Frage
die er stellen muss um das eigene Trauma
vom 7 Oktober zu überwinden er wird
Antworten bekommen und wir begkleiten
ihn
dabei ja das ist ein Moment dass ich in
seit seit mehr als einem Monat da drauf
warte und von daher ja ich freue mich
aber ich bin schon auch sehr
angespannt Ankunft auf den Gängen des
Flughafens Bilder von
Geiseln als wir gerade losfahren
wollen
raketenalarm der nächste Bunker zu weit
weg der Weg dahin zu
gefährlich
jetzt sind wir wirklich
angekommen nach einiger Zeit Entwarnung
endlich auf dem Weg nach mas nach
Hause doch dann Autopanne mitten auf der
Schnellstraße es dauert nicht lange bis
ein arabischer Jugendlicher dazu kommt
der junge Beduine wohnt gleich nebenan
und will sofort helfen wenige Minuten
später hält auch noch ein
jüdischisraelischer Reservist an und
Pack zu ein Auftag der Reise zwischen
den Kulturen Zusammenhalt ganz praktisch
so kennt so liebt Meron Mendel sein
[Applaus]
Israel ja geradeaus immer geradeaus und
wir sind fast
da zuerst die Eltern besuchen Vater und
Mutter umarmen das ist ihm
wichtig Wiedersehen nach einem Jahr
wiedersehen nach 7
Oktober was gibt neues in
kibut nicht
viel na ja es herrscht Krieg das
bestimmt den
Alltag sind viele auf dem kibut
mobilisiert
worden natürlich die Armee ist in
Generalmobilmachung alle Reservisten
wurden
eingezogen für die eigene Existenz
kämpfamitach Oktober 73 lernen sich
seine Eltern im jomkipurkrie kennen
viele Geschichten auch romantische
beginnen in Israel mit einer
Schlacht mein Vater war im
Unabhängigkeitskrieg und im sechagekrieg
ich im jomkipur Krieg ihr im
Libanonkrieg und jetzt eh im gaz
Krieg merons Mutter sorgt sich um Israel
und um ihre Söhne der Jüngste ist an der
Front Tag werden z D vi Soldaten
getötet ich bin sehr
besorgt in diesem kibutz ist mer Mendel
groß geworden mitten in der
negerfüste die Bäume die die Wiesen das
ist Teil des Konzeptes kibutzes die
Wüste blühen zu lassen und da sind in
diese h sind trainingsgebiete der der
Armee ich bin ofter also in der alte
Zeiten hier so gerannt und
geschossen jetzt gibt es keine
Schießübungen die meisten der Soldaten
sind wohl im
gasereinsatz Rücksicht nehmen hart
arbeiten Teilen statt besitzen Werte die
seine Entwicklung stark beeinflusst
haben jetzt kommen wir zur
Schule das ist ganz normal also da oben
läuft der Krieg da unten ist ganz
normale Schulunterricht
viel spannender als der Krieg unsere
Kamera vor 40 Jahren war Meron selbst
ein Schüler wie
sie ist jemand a der Näh von
Gaza das Tor bleibt abgeschlossen
überall Soldaten man will sich schützen
gegen
Terroristen welche Werte wurden dir als
Kind hier vermitt für Menschen wird man
hier in
erzogen das wichtigste ist
so produktive Mensch zu sein also was
was beizutragen der der Gemeinschaft
beizutragen die ganze
kibutzbewegung ist Teil der
Friedensbewegung also hier gibt's kaum
jemand der die nationalistische
Regierung nan unterstürzt das aber
bedeutet nicht dass dass man gemischt
mit Palästinenser auch
aufwächst offen gegenüber anderen
Kulturen sein mit allen in Frieden leben
und doch Abstand halten diese
Einstellung gilt im kibutz nach wie vor
Mons Vater malt seit vielen Jahren der
71jährige setzt sich mit den Problemen
der Beduinen auseinander etwa 200 000
Leben von ihnen in Israel dem arabischen
Nomadenvolk wird eher wenig Beachtung
geschenkt es ist nicht zu glauben das
sind Hochspannungsleitungen und sie
verlaufen über deren Hütten die alle aus
Blech gebaut
sind in dieser plechütte lebt RA merons
Vater besucht ihn
regelmäßig Tee trinken sich austauschen
für die beiden ganz normal doch es ist
eine Freundschaft mit Grenzen diese
Grenzen wurden auch Meron Mendel
beigebracht mit arabischen
Nachbarskindern spielen ja sie als
Bewohner des kibuts aufnehmen nein ein
Grund kibuim sind weitesgehend homogene
Gemeinschaften bis heute je älter er
wurde desto mehr stellte in Frage und
baute sich einen Freundeskreis auf indem
man sich aktiv für Frieden und die
Begegnung zwischen jüdischen und
arabischen Israelis
[Musik]
einsetzt dazu gehört Avital Ben schalom
die beiden verbindet eine enge und
langjährige Freundschaft sie steht jeden
Tag hier demonstriert für die
Freilassung aller verschleppten ein
Wunsch den jeder Israeli hier in sich
trägt
das sind die zwei süßen
Rotschöpfe aus
ber was für schlimme
Geschichten ich habe es noch gar nicht
geschafft zu
weinen einander Halt geben fon ein
wichtiger
Moment ich bin ziemlich wütend weil ich
denke dass die Befreiung der Menschen
nicht das erste
Ziel das sollte
es mitten unter den Demonstrierenden
Shaul Levi ein Freund der Familie er
kennt Miron von klein auf seine
19-jährige Enkelin Nama wurde
verschleppt die Bilder gingen um die
Welt doch anstatt getröstet zu werden
tröstet
er sei
stark ich kann nicht diese Bilder von
Nama gehen wir nicht aus dem Kopf ich
weiß nicht wie du das aushörst
man atmet tief ein und überwindet sich
es gibt keinen anderen
[Applaus]
Weg die junge Soldatin stand gerade am
Anfang ihres
Militärdienstes wollte Diplomatin werden
setzte sich für Aussöhnung
ein sie war mehrmals im Ausland bei fen
namens of peace wo man sich mit
Palästinensern
trifft ihre Chancen jemals freizukommen
sind ungewiss ihr Großvater glaubt dann
noch an ein gutes Ende für Nama und ganz
Israel es gibt
Hoffnung das ist nicht mal Hoffnung ich
bin mir sicher dass wir zu dem richtigen
Weg zurückfinden
werden eine Stärke die Miron
beeindruckt Hoffnung und Trauer liegen
landen beieinander Meron Mendel erlebt
eine Heimat die verwundet ist sich aber
nicht geschlagen gibt ich bin ein
bisschen optimistischer als ich vor paar
Tage war weil weil ich sehr dann einfach
diese Entschlossenheit
egal was passiert das hat doch Avital
gesagt und hat Shaul gesagt wir sind
vielleicht jetzt tief am Boden aber
jetzt kann der Aufbau Beginen also wir
Ken Neustart machen mussen unsere
Zukunfts neu denken und was dafür tun
und das ich finde es so stark eine
Zuversicht die immer wieder auf die
Probe gestellt
[Musik]
wird Zukunft Neudenken das müssen auch
die vielen geflüchteten im Land einer
von ihnen ist it ein Studienfreund von
Miron die deutschisraelische Familie
lebte in einem Grenzort zu Gaza bis vor
z Monaten sie wollen dahin zurück wissen
es zu Hause aussieht Jen Samstag ich
wollte kann sich erinnern einige vor
einige Jahren wir waren noch mit zwei
Freunde von mir aus Deutschland wir sind
durch die wü gewandert mit Schlaf
Schlafsack und alles und die ein von den
Freunde hat dich gefragt wie ist das an
der Grenze zu Gaza zu leben und D hast
du ganz so locker gesagt ja es ist kein
Problem die raketten weil wir so nah an
der Grenze sind die Raketen fliegen über
uns nach askelo nach Tel Aviv bei uns
ist es sicher sicher sein seit dem 7
oktober gibt es dieses Gefühl nicht mehr
stundenlang versuchte Meron seinen
Freund zu erreichen erst spät am Abend
die Gewissheit sie sind am
Leben einfach die schönste Nachrichten
die ich in mein Leben bekommen
[Musik]
habe der Ort wirkt fast wie ausgestorben
bei einem Alarm hat man 15 Sekunden Zeit
um sich in Sicherheit zu bringen
Schutzräume stehen überall viele haben
sie am 7 Oktober
aufgesucht eine alte Frau die ich sehr
gut kannte die Mutter einer
Kindheitsfreundin ist von ihrem Haus
hinter diesen Bäumen in den Schutzraum
hier gerannt ein Terrorist sah sie und
hat sie da drin
erschossen 20 Nachbarn hat itai an
diesem Tag verloren wer hier gelebt hat
ist entweder tot oder geflüchtet sie
wurden mitten aus dem Leben gerissen nur
ein paar verlassene Katzen streunen noch
herum auch heute sind immer wieder
Explosionen zu hören der Gazastreifen
ist nur wenige hundert Meter
entfernt in Gaza war ich als Kind sehr
oft zwar nicht in diesem Teil sondern
direkt am Strand also das war der
nächste Strand der vom kibut war und wir
wir haben mit palästinische Kinder im
Sand gespielt das war ganz andere Zeiten
als heute und all der Zerstörung zum
Trotz sobald it in seine Straße einbiegt
fühlt er sich zu Hause was ist unsere
auf ah
wier zu Hause ja und
hier das ist so kleine
Schutzraum und wir waren hier am 7
Oktober hier war eine Matratze und zwei
und ich habe von von die Kuhlschrank
Sachen
genommen über Stunden haben sie im
Dunkel
verraine
versteckten zwei lange Küchenmesser im
Schrank also wir wir hatten die Idee
wenn jemand reinkommt dann verstecke ich
mich hier genau und sie haben dann
Messer hattest du Angst ja
sehr ein paar Lebensmittel die
Lieblingskleidung um wenigstens ein
bisschen Alltag
mitzunehmen ob sie hier jemals wieder
leben können möchte zurück aber ich
wünsche dass sicher hier zurück zu
kommen wir sind Frieden Menschen und wir
denken dass die Losung ist Frieden und
es war ja auch so dass wir uns vor dem 7
Oktober total sicher fühlten hier also
es wir dachten wir leben im
Hochsicherheitstrakt also ähm wir haben
das Haus nicht abgesperrt wir hatten den
Autoschlüssel im Schloss stecken
teilweise und die Kinder sind nachts
waren nachts unterwegs mit Freunden im
Dorf und es war alles total sicher
dachten wir
und mir hat sich rausgestellt es ist
nicht sicher es ist überhaupt gar nicht
sicher man spürt die Zerrissenheit hier
ist ihr zu Hause oder
war momentan wohnen Sie bei Verwandten
etwa vier Autostunden von hasa entfernt
dort treffen wir frautin und Tochter
wieder kommt aus München am 7 Oktober
war sie gerade in Deutschland musste per
WhatsApp von der Terrorattacke
erfahren ist natürlich wahnsinnig
schlimm wenn du dann irgendwie 3000 km
weiter weg in dem Zimmer sitzt und
nichts tun kannst es waren Stunden der
Todesangst nicht wissend ob sie ihre
Familie je wiedersieht Hass aber hätte
Tini nie empfunden sondern Mitgefühl für
die Menschen in
Gaza ich kann NS dran
ist aber ich glaube einfach dieses
Gefühl ist wichtig zu haben dass man da
nicht irgendwie total zacht und und kein
Mitgefühl mehr
hat Maja trotz dem Schrecken der Hamas
mit unerschütterlicher Hoffnung ihre
Zukunft sieht sie in
Israel ich liebe Israel ich weiß nicht
ob mein Wunsch zu groß ist aber
natürlich Frieden weil vor diese Krieg
es gab hier viel Hass auch nicht
zwischen die Palästinenser und die
Israelis schon auch zwischen die
Menschen in Israel
und einfach dass
wir lieben und
und die andere
sehen der 7 Oktober dürfe weder ihre
Familie Spalten noch ihre Werte
zerstören auch nicht den Glauben an ein
friedliches
Israel
nicht alle von merons Freunden haben
überlebt schacha und Jan schlomi wurden
brutal
ermordet schachas Familie ist wie ein
zweites Zuhause für Meron mit ihrem
Bruder Juda ist er befreundet seit sie
15 sind für die Eltern ist Meron wie ein
eigener sohnkmen wie geht fragt der der
selbst gerade Trost
braucht bei Mutter rachel ist jedes Wort
überflüssig
bei der Beisetzung habe ich mich dabei
ertappt wie ich die Worte des
manchmal bin es ich manchmal bist es du
der den Trost so sehr braucht ich hatte
das Gefühl dass es wichtig ist dass wir
jetzt einander
trösten ein Lied das schacha selbst
viele Male gesungen
[Musik]
hat
Schache das bedeutet Morgendämmerung sie
war bekannt für ihr sanftmütiges Herz
überzeugt von
Frieden ihr Tod für die Familie
unbegreiflich unsere Kinder haben immer
an gegenseitiges Verständnis
geglaubt sie waren gegen das
stereotypisieren und gegen
Hass Zeugung dass es wichtig ist sich
mit Menschen zu verbinden die anders
sind die einen anderen Glauben haben
nicht nur eine andere Sprache sondern
eine andere
Kultur schacha und J man schlomi zogen
bewusst ins kibutolit wohlwissend dass
sie Nähe zu Gaza auch zu Gefahr werden
kann einschüchtern ließen sie sich nicht
ihr Wunsch die Gesellschaft positiv
beeinflussen gemeinsam haben sie eine
jüdischarabische Schule
mitgegründet hatte eine besondere Freude
die sie an andere weitergab ich vermisse
sie nur se Tage vor ihrem Tod feierten
sie ihren 50
Geburtstag lachend herzlich offen so war
Schacher so war das Israel für dass sie
starb sie war so glücklich schlomi war
so glücklich und sie waren so
verliebt so will ich sie in Erinnerung
behalten m nicht auf ihren schrelich to
fokussieren mit dem Verlust umzugehen
sucht Vater Ilan nach einer rationalen
Erklärung seine Analyse deramas ginge es
um die Vernichtung aller
Juden hast du deine politische Meinung
nach dem 7 Oktober
geändert im Gegenteil ich bin nur noch
mehr davon überzeugt dass der einzige
Weg die zweienösung
für mich ist es der Beweis dass es
unmöglich ist dass ein Volk dieses ganze
Gebiet einnehmen
wird es kann also auch ein Wendepunkt
sein der 7 oktober als Wendepunkt daran
würden Sie gerne glauben Mutter Rachel
gibt aber auch zu es war noch nie so
schwer an Frieden
festzuhalten und das gegenseitige
Verständnis einzusetzen wenn man es mit
jemandem zu tun hat der Frieden
grundsätzlich
ablehnt Meron möchte am Grab Abschied
nehmen überraschend kommt rotem dazu der
Sohn von schacha und schlumi er erzählt
von seinem Überleben und dem Tod die
Familie rannte in den Schutzraum seine
Mutter sagte ihm er solle sich zwischen
Wand und Bett
verstecken dann legte sie sich auf mich
ich hörte die Angreifer allahu akbar
schreien und sie haben die Tür
gesprengt mein Vater schrie dass er
seinen Arm verloren habe weil er
wahrscheinlich in die Luft gesprengt
wurde es gab Schüsse und sie warfen eine
Granate seine Eltern waren sofort tot
fast eine Stunde verhte rotem unter
seiner
Mutter
ich habe dann den toten Körper meiner
Mutter weggeschoben und gesehen dass
Körperteile auf dem Bett
lagen ihm blieb keine Zeit den Anblick
zu verkraften wieder hörte er Stimmen
von
Terroristen also rannte ich in das
Schlafzimmer meiner Eltern und habe mir
eine Decke
übergestülbt dann habe ich zu Gott
gebetet nicht zum Gott der Juden oder zu
Allah einfach zu irgendeinem Gott
der 16-Jährige musste 10 Stunden warten
bis Hilfe kam er wurde bei dem Anschlag
schwer verwundet aber ohne die
Aufopferung seiner Eltern hätte er nicht
überlebt für mich sind sie wahre
Helden auf dem Grabstein ein Vers aus
dem hoheled viele Wasser können die
Liebe nicht auslöschen noch die Ströme
sie
ertränkten
[Musik]
Israel erlebt nicht nur auf jüdischer
Seite Verlust und Schmerz wir sind auf
dem Weg ins Arabische xsal fahren vorbei
an jüdischen
Siedlungen werden wir jetzt ein ganz
anderes Israel sehen als bisher ja
Israel ist sehr vielfältig und das ist
das ist Teil von Israel wir fahren jetzt
nicht nach Westbank wir sind zwar so
gerade jetzt an der Grenze zu Westbank
aber al ist Teil von Israel das ist Teil
der israelische Gesellschaft
die Menschen dort sind fühlen sich als
palästinens abertinens mit israelische
statsehörigkeit so auch Mohammad der
Rauschen für Meron Mendel enger Freund
und Vorbild zugleich sie verbindet die
gemeinsame Friedensarbeit zwischen
Palästinensern und Juden der 7 oktober
trifft ihn ganz persönlich die Hamas
machte keinen Halt vor Palästinensern
auch sie waren Zielscheibe unter ihnen
Mohammads couson
au er wollte Leben retten das war sein
Traum der 23jährige war als
Rettungssanitäter auf dem Supernova
Festival als der Terror begann war er
die erste Anlaufstelle für viele
[Musik]
verletzte er hatte Verbandszeug in den
Händen lief von einer verletzten Person
zu anderen bis die Schüsse näher
kam seine Kollegen Ranen um ihr Leben a
weigerte
sich er sagte ihr geht ich spreche
arabisch ich komme schon
klar keine 60 Sekunden später trafen ihn
zwei Schüsse auf seiner Beerdigung
beteten sowohl muslimische Imame als
auch jüdische Rabbiner a ST als stolzer
Palästinenser und stolzer
Israeli
is paler Juden Araber Muslime Christen
wer auch immer an Werten wie
Menschlichkeit orientieren dann wären
Entscheidungen vielleicht
anders den Dialog suchen Brücken bauen
statt Grenzen ziehen eine Denkweise die
im kleinen beginnt z.B beim
Kaffee das ist typisch
israelisch und das passt zur deutschen
Kultur alle Kulturen in deiner
Küche ja aber das ist der beste riech
mal gemeinsam arabischen Kaffee kochen
damit ist es nicht getan schnell sind
sie wieder beim
Thema ich glaube ohne eine politische
Lösung werden wir viele 7 oktober haben
die Palästinenser verdienen es dass ihre
Menschenwürde geschützt wird und das ist
unter der Besatzung nicht
möglich
für Mohammad ist die Besatzung nicht ein
Problem für ihn ist sie das
Problem angenommen Hamas gibt es nicht
mehr wird Israel den palästinens nach
dem Ende von Hamas einen Staat
geben nein und das ist das Problem ich
denke es ist etwas komplizierter es gibt
nicht nur eine Meinung in Isel es gibt
verschiedene ich habe noch keinen
einzigen Iseli
gehereit ST anzuerkennen ich kenne
einige ich stimme dir zu die Besatzung
ist ein sehr großes Problem die
sielungen sind ein riesengroßes
Problem Diskussionen führen und
aushalten ein wichtiger Beitrag es
brauche aber auch politischen Willen und
der fehle da sind sich die beiden
einig wir können persönlichen Frieden
schaffen du als Jude und ich als
Palästinenser aber es muss zu einem
kollektiven Frieden übergehen für einen
kollektiven Frieden braucht man
politische Strukturen
einfache Lösungen gibt es in diesem
Konflikt
nicht konntest du nachvollziehen dass er
aber wirklich da auch ganz scharf
kritisiert hat wenn wir dieses
besatzungsproblem und die Politik nicht
ändern dann werden wir 1 7 Oktober nach
dem anderen haben also mohammed hat 100%
Recht wenn er den Besatzung kritisiert
ich finde es aber von der Analyse
problematisch wenn er sagt nur die
Besatzung ist das Problem und stückweise
das V meinen Gefühlen Gespräch hatte die
Hamas aus der Verantwortung gezogen hat
gesagt so das ist so eine so eine
Gesetzmäßigkeit dann muss die Hamas so
handeln wenn die Besatzung
andauert Freundschaft trotz desenz
andere zu Wort kommen lassen auch wenn
sie einem
widersprechen Grundsätze die für Meron
Mendel in Israel zu kurz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommen
besonders deutlich wird das im
Westjordanland genau da fahren wir hin
unser Ziel Hebron schon immer ein
Hotspot im naostkonflikt nirgends stehen
sich Siedler und Palästinenser so direkt
gegenüber hier hat Meron Mendel als
junger Soldat viel Zeit
verbracht wie sieht die Stadt heute aus
vor allem nach dem 7
Oktober
was ist die stärkste Erinnerung die du
von Hebron hast die silerin Hebron die
aus der dcher von von der Häuser dann
auf Passanten Steine beborfen haben ja
das das ist schon eine sehr krasse
rassistische Ideologie dieser dieser die
sie dort lernen von von Null auf dass
sie besser sind 1997 wurde die Stadt
geteilt in eine palästinensische und
eine jüdische Zone letztere wird vom
israelischen Militär kontrolliert mitten
im palästinensischen Teil liegt der
Markt Händler unterbieten sich mit
gemüsepreisen es wirkt skuril normal
Meron sieht aber auch die Stadt hat sich
verändert und das nicht zum Positiven
früher war diese Straße noch
offen also hier sind wir schon sozusagen
die erste Siedlungen von Hebron also
hier sind wir gerade auf
palästinensischenem Gebiet genau und da
drüben ist israelisches Gebiet Jain also
sozusagen die diese Siedlung ist ist
jüdisch aber das Haus nebenan ist
palästinensisch das heißt die das sind
wirklich da einzelne Häuser die verteilt
sind auf diese
Straße auf die jüdische Seite dürfen wir
nicht die Soldaten schicken uns zum
nächsten Checkpoint sie hat gefragt ob
ich J also ob wir Juden sind also das
ist echt reinzukommen um reinzukommen
das ist echt
ja ich bin echt
schockiert W hast du prüfen unsere Pässe
und pressekarten bleiben aber dabei
weiter kommen wir an diesem Tag nicht da
Leben ich weiß wie viel tausende
Palästinenser und jetzt sie sind
praktisch so in einer Art von Gefängnis
ich weiß nicht wie sie dann reinkommen
zu ihrer Häuser vielleicht sind mussen
sie schon ihr Häuser verlassen die
Antwort Volk bromt dieser Palästinenser
lebt im jüdischen
Teil sie öffnen das Tor nur sonntagstag
und Donnerstag von 7 Uhr morgens bis 5
Uhr
nachmittags der Zugang sei seit dem 7
Oktober noch strenger reguliert Schikane
gehöre zu ihrem
Alltag unser Leben ist eine Tragödie wir
leben in einem großen Gefängnis wir
dürfen die Fenster nicht öffnen Frauen
werden angegriffen und wir nutzen die
Dächer um unsere Wäsche aufzuhängen
heute ist Samstag die Siedler trinken
Alkohol und werfen die Flaschen gegen
unsere
Fenster als heon geteilt wurde R 35000
Palästinenser in der jüdischen Zone 10
Jahre später hatten schon über 40% von
ihnen die Gegend
verlassen diese jüdische Siedler haben
in dieser stad nicht zu suchen und noch
großer zu sagen also insgesamt Siler den
westb Westbank Leben haben auch nicht zu
suchen in diesem stückland die einzige
Lösung für diese Konflikt ist diese
zweatenlösung emfall friedlich
nebeneinander wohnen hier scheint das
unmöglich es gibt in Israel aber auch
Orte an denen sich Juden und
Palästinenser ganz ohne Vorbehalte
begegnen können diese Ansätze müssten
umso mehr gefördert werden meint Meron
Mendel so wie bei diesen Jungs und
Mädchen für Meron Mendel wre
Hoffnungsträger es ist die einzige
zweisparige Schule im Süden Israels ein
Projekt das den Pädagogen ganz besonders
am Herzen liegt hier trifft der Avital
wieder sie leitet die
[Musik]
Schule das ist unsere
Schule wir haben eine Vision für die
Schule wie man eine gleichberechtigte
Lernumgebung für jüdische und arabische
Schülerschaft
über 300 Kinder bis zur sechsten Klasse
lernen hier Seite an Seite und das seit
15 Jahren auch jetzt in Kriegszeiten sie
haben eine kleine trauerecke
eingerichtet
[Musik]
sie zeigen ihr Mitgefühl mit den
Soldaten den Familien hier in Israel
oder in
Gaza es ist wie ein sicherer
Ort sie legen einfach Ihren Brief hier
hinein manche der Kinder teilen ihre
Gedanken ganz offen so wie naem der
jährige hat einen Brief an die Jungen
und Mädchen in Gaza
geschrieben
er schrieb ihr seid uns wichtig und wir
wollen euch helfen aber im Moment müsst
ihr einfach versuchen zu überleben hört
nicht auf daran zu glauben dass ihr es
schaffen
werdet er hat das zwar an Kinder
geschrieben aber es ist auch eine
Botschaft an uns
Eltern ich hoffe die Kinder die in so
einer Umgebung hier aufwachsen werden
die Regierungschefs der Zukunft dann
haben wir vielleicht
Hoffnung ein jüdisches Kind in Israel
drückt einem arab
g instinktiv sein Mitgefühl aus es wirkt
banal und ist doch ein kleines
Wunder sie besuchen eine erste Klasse
man spürt wie wichtig Avital ihre
Schützlinge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sind
[Musik]
es war toll zu sehen dass sie sich
einfach lieb
haben sie sind ganz tolle Kinder aber
sie sind auch privilegiert in solch
einer Zeit zusammen zu
sein das Privileg sich nicht hassen zu
müssen dreiviertel der israelischen
Bevölkerung sind Juden etwa 20% Araber
Israels Schulen sind in der Regel
unterteilt in Arabisch und
jüdisch wir sind beide ja in einem
segregierten Schulsystem aufgewachsen
wieso
eigentlich das ist ein Grundproblem der
israelischen
[Musik]
Gesellschaft ein jüdisches Kind hat
keine Gelegenheit sich mit einem
arabischen Kind zu treffen bis es
vielleicht zur Universität
geht doch bis dahin haben sich
Überzeugungen und Vorurteile of schon
verest
genau das will arabischlehrerin Samira
aufbrechen man muss das Erbe der
islamischen der jüdischen der
christlichen Kulturen kennen dann kann
man den Weg des Hasses verlassen Wege
der Liebe aufzeigen und sie wachsen
lassen wenn du mich verstehst und ich
dich bleibt kein Platz mehr für H dann
ist Liebe
da die Zukunft Israels sieht die
28jährige durch die Augen ihrer Schüler
da wird keiner sagen geh weg du bist ein
Araber mit dir spiele ich nicht oder geh
weg du bist ein Jude nein sie sind eine
Gemeinschaft mit diesen Kindern sehe ich
also eine bessere Zukunft solange Sie
diesen Weg weitergehen es wird auch
unser ganzes Land in eine bessere
Zukunft führen und wie sehen es die
Kinder ich hoffe dass es Frieden geben
wird ich kann das im Namen von fast
allen Kindern in der Schule
sagen wenn Sie sehen dass ich Araberin
bin fragen sie zu wem gehörst du
Palästina oder Israel ich sage dann ich
respektiere jeden ich gehö zu von
beiden die Juden lernen unsere Sprache
und wir Araber lernen ihre Sprache sie
lernen unsere Feiertage wir lernen ihre
Feiertage es macht einfach Spaß an
dieser Schule zu
sein es sind Sätze wie diese die Avital
motivieren für sie der einzig richtige
Weg damit irgendwann Frieden herrschen
kann auch wenn es noch ein sehr weiter
Weg ist gut was wir hier haben ist es 1%
der Schulsystem 99% ist segregiert und
wir msen das genau auf den Kopf stellen
also muss wenn 99% gemischt
aufwachsen dann ist wirklich dann ein
Frieden von unten
möglich echte Friedensarbeit beginnt
durch Bildung davon ist Meron Mendel
überzeugt und es sei nie zu spät damit
anzufangen wie geht es weiter mit meinem
Israel eine Frage die sich Meron Mendel
seit dem 7 Oktober immer wieder gestellt
hat die Reise ist fast zu Ende wie
blickst du auf diese letzten a Tage ich
habe die Menschen getroffen die die mir
sehr am Herzen liegen Menschen die ich
zum Teil 40 oder 30 Jahre kenne und
verbindet uns sehr sehr viele und ich
habe sie trotzdem ganz anders erlebt als
normalerweise sie hat dann ein Jahr dass
sie vollig neu geformt haben ich meine
nicht nur der 7 Oktober sie haben ein
Jahr für die Demokratie gekämpft gegen
die Regierung dann seit Oktober kämpften
sie vor ihr Existenz das ist das Gefühl
die alle gesagt haben es geht unsere
istenz was für eine Zukunft siehst du
für dieses Land
Israel also was mir eine was mir
Hoffnung gibt ist gerade diese
Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft der
Zivilgesellschaft und alle mit denen wir
gesprochen haben haben vor allem an
einem Punkt ein Punkt sehr stark gemacht
das war die Wunsch nach Frieden sowohl
mit Palästinenser mit den wir gesprochen
haben wie Mohammed darusche als auch mit
mit jüdische Israel ist und das das ist
schon so eine funkvolle verhoffnung se
wirklich sehr dunkle
Zeiten jeder ist verwundet ob Jude oder
Palästinenser sie sind vereint im
geteilten Leid genau darin liegt eine
Chance Versöhnung zu schaffen Israel
gemeinsam zu denken Meron Mendel hat
Menschen erlebt die den Willen und die
Kraft dazu haben und seinen eigenen
Glauben an Frieden stärken konnten seine
Heimat war selten so zerbrechlich ihre
Zukunft so gefährdet und doch fühlt er
sich dem Land und den Menschen
den
[Musik]
je